Now that you know all about K-fold cross validation for
validating the performance of your algorithm,
I want to show you a different use of it that I really love.
Remember back to very early in the class we were talking about
machine learning algorithms like naive bayse support vector machines and
decision trees and especially the parameters that you have tune for
these to get the best performance out.
The way we were tuning these parameters was kind of with a guess and
check method.
But as it turns out this is really clunky.
It takes a long time.
Nobody likes to do it.
It's just the worst.
Cross validation can actually help you out here.
It can automate a lot of that testing.
And pick our the parameter tune that's going to be best.
So let me show you how to do that.